Who should Christians side with in the war?
This is a great question.
And the answers found in the Bible several times.
Go to Luke chapter 11,
where Jesus says,
he who is not with me is against me,
and he who does not gather with me, scatter.
The simple fact is
anybody who does not love Jesus as the king of kings,
Lord of Lords over the earth.
Yes, he owns the planet.
Every single human being is under his authority.
So for us Christians,
our allegiance is not to any geopolitical
real, or Canada or Mexico,
you name it.
He who does not obey the sun will not see life,
but the wrath of god.
God abides on him.
We know that.
The love of god abides on us Christians,
but the wrath of god abides on non believers out there.
I know there's a lot of people who are gonna say, oh,
but the choose.
Israel is God's chosen people.
It's his chosen nation. Therefore
we have to support Israel and whatever they do.
But of course,
this just comes from a misunderstanding
of what Israel actually is.
Israel is not a place,
it's people.
If you wanna learn some more about this topic,
then just go to this YouTube video where I prove
that the Jews are not actually God's chosen people.
According to the scriptures, of course.
So basically
we should support righteous people
and not support wicked people. So simple.